[Music]
yeah buddy homo no homo root Scuderia
hormones are you ready mask it off
Schettino viva la la carte omaima's
[Music]
retraction on of Iowa
Sasaki you taganas hey kono michi knee
height on Raja Raja colleges so
regardless cara ikuyo Giovanna d'arco
Simoni pencast a Hema konnichi Alma's
homer no suits curiosity
janila see you at all - OH -
[Music]
and miss anymore anymore do harmless
dose a woman missing emoji re mascara
story should not a true shock to me know
Kate Orthodox in Tiana's tiburtina say
taco taco taco taco rice - taxi -
Layla's Halle Berry is do a fool
damn it a bit 18 watch watch the koalas
McCain watch is its measure 9 s Korea
Russia Russia Cologne Germany actually
the more she needed a yes a large table
knock who know value a so muggy today
futhermore super Ashima notes Kaiba so
doc a cure that's a chic shut up whoever
hit the local Sonia prosciutto much Eid
company sterno in Ochoa's gotta go
destroy morale desu kedo say Italians
anomalous Schettino Miniver aha Lockhart
omaima's
in Japan restaurants and to be clear I
mean a ton of restaurants use plastic
food displays to entice customers and in
google province there's a small factory
that's responsible for more than half of
all the plastic sushi crab omelettes
duck ramen beef oh my god
that's all plastic this is SATA a kabuki
yatta schewe Sesotho con us to do a
coconut oil joining us this Factory has
about 30 full-time artists because all
these plastic foods are made by hand
chica esto no dos mo mo suteki na mo na
anata cinemas on o de hitori kazuki Rito
Yuka so emo no no Hong ah di una de mas
uno de Aparri chika diva moody todo mi
los Cuates anandamaya ishigami Takahiro
this Takahiro is an artist here Nestle
toreano hitori de NOS Angelo Cunnane una
hata titled anonymous a piranha
so no mo no no 10 on Ashoka Hinton on
non-monetary Misano dare nominee no
economic an ER a mistake serega to you
Iman Omaha no boom Katamari Ishiguro not
very much this trend of plastic food in
Japan has been around since the 1930s
but blew up in the 50s and it is
everywhere however this food it doesn't
come cheap
chisaem Onoda star amazon very angry
descoteaux mo Okemo no OT ba cannon toka
Okemo no not chato a GU Myung jus my n
to you
it takes years of training to master
this art sight a demonise on a no su a
night o mo not screen I Kuna motorist
quick example a bowl of ramen might take
three hours to make while a fish many
many more
Oh Dominique Moore tornado nsk doe an a
sureno su cricketer Turkish Oviedo Mon
Ami team esto hey pally boy who needs
good para he know Couture see you Naruto
common Misano de a body so in mono no
mediocre des neige Canada homo knowledge
cascade Kakaako today you know can I
take some people associate instant
noodles with broke college students but
instant ramen wasn't created for a bunch
of hungry 20 year olds the man who
invented them was much more ambitious he
set out to solve a hunger crisis in
Japan after World War two food shortages
plagued Japanese cities so the u.s.
supplied wheat flour and encouraged the
Japanese to make bread one man named
Momofuku Ando didn't understand why his
people would make bread instead of
noodles something that was already part
of their culture on do decided to take
matters into his own hands and create a
new ramen made to last
he spent a year trying to figure out how
to preserve the noodles
he needed a non perishable tasty and
easy recipe but it was a challenge to
maintain the robust flavors and unique
texture that most people were accustomed
to it wasn't until his wife was making
dinner one night and he threw some
noodles in a bowl of hot tempura oil
that he realized flash frying the
noodles was the answer he had been
looking for this method not only
dehydrated them it left small
perforations that allowed the noodles to
recut quickly and there you have it
instant ramen noodles became an instant
success undos products gained notoriety
when he introduced the packaged ramen in
the 1950s and later cup noodles in 1978
his company began selling upwards of 40
billion units every year
and Momofuku ndu became a culinary icon
in japan so the next time you heat up a
cup of instant noodles remember you're
slurping down a little piece of history
[Music]
- Lotus Ahmadi market - lockers at a
ryokan anagen my snake
my market enormous I hope you enjoy
Cheng are evocative you take slow
honking no a escoger montages Oh - Diego
Zoo good I'm anonymous
the pseudo sake brewery in Obara Japan
might be the oldest in the world
situated in a lush Valley the brewery is
surrounded by ancient trees oh no ma da
da da three enoki attacks on each arena
more QE Haku Negri's Tony I don't know
me des Eaux Nokia desde ahora nos a
kazoo kazoo kazoo Cassini Coca Cola tow
sama dama na sono zapatos de grado
yukata names tsuki garden all day in
mrs. Mehta crate re Sakura carajo
so not sue his ass karma Mata ki jai ho
today motto no DC no toki mo anata mo no
esta aqui no mega hype eternal day
addition we are acoustic guitar the 2011
earthquake caused structural damage to
the brewery but the real fear was
radiation from the subsequent nuclear
meltdown the mawashi mango chicken sorry
dodo you know Cotabato agua es aqui
tsukuyomi Humberto a Sunni Hashanah na
caixa kyoka ket a sustained and
overnight Takata market an Eskimo boom
boom Connie with our eco circuits on
Akane Mona's a shaman on holiday but I
do say katsu Yoshiki so Esther Monaco's
embassy own ego ego Sarita samosa
manometer conferred on no second soon
Akane
super annoyed on nice paragon Kuniko
huge comedy Noah
Kotoko today Yuto Osaka back during
Aragon today's this rattle attorney and
Osaka a humble City Hotel enact a
samovar a tsunami on the moon
carcinogens are so stubborn or a Nakata
knee meet saw how much bigger shock
Italian dough need you Sonny
Latinas dento taking a boom Kadima after
the snare mom oh my dear titoki new ammo
omochi bar hornets chemo nonetheless
oshio mucho add the snare Yamaha kakuta
yoku no b ro spot oregano v dou mu Qi go
me tell you come a goddess named kono
machi go meant a screw naga omochi
Nanda's not new hunger a chic alto
haircut ski mask cordova reglas coming
time' Mura
jellies an Angus cattle much even no
cheeky with the snare on Ohio mucukunda
vamos a cheeky don't know Mochizuki
Irina's kedomo i know it ponte Kinyua
sideshow Cara story got three story got
Panero tener the issue an Oklahoma
Jessica torrential that you range you a
nice neck
ma gbo need skis on kites wicked tell
you go to that Andy's career ah I know
Tadashi no kata you know ah I know more
about timing with Kinane this time in
Waterloo time I need a snare daddy I
know
Koyukuk a negara I know yari muscle show
code on this mo Shin King show Buddhist
karate omochi skill what is net so this
an adult Imelda Chema's yogi sahadeva
Jarrod demos Ignis kimochi Haggadah Oh
muchos idiomas no de Poissy Muno Tabata
toki no cow ningún doge doge no kalgard
Oh mon Dieu de pouso no Cabo mrs. J eat
are a guru Kaluga von Shabazz's net
[Music]